For this video, I’m going to show you how
to use electricity and water to blow up a
party balloon like a mad scientist. These
might look like any other party balloons,
but there’s one major difference. These
ones explode.
Let’s start this project with the “Water
to Fuel Generator” we made in a previous
project, and two, fully charged car batteries.
You can see I’ve got a 4 gauge cable connecting
the positive terminal on one battery, to the
negative terminal on the other. And by hooking the jumper cables to the other two posts, we’ve
just created a series circuit that will power
our generator.
If we remove the cap from the bubbler and
pour in a bit of fresh water, it will push
out any of the stale air, and give us a safe
watery platform, for testing small amounts of the gas.
Let’s go ahead and power up the generator
by connecting the jumper cables to the two
terminals at the top.
And look at the way the water instantly, begins
bubbling and churning. That’s because the
electricity is ripping the water molecules
apart, and converting them into hydrogen and
oxygen gas, which make a pretty explosive
combination. So, guess what we’re going to try next?
First we’ll need to push the cap back onto
the bubbler, so the gas will flow through
the plastic tubing at the top. This way, we
can direct it wherever we want.
So what do you think would happen, if we tried
blowing up a latex party balloon?
You can see I wrapped a thick elastic band
around the tube and the balloon multiple times,
so they’ll stay together hands free. That
means we’ll be able to fill our balloons
up safely, from a distance.
Now the generator works just fine regardless
of how the the leads are connected, but when
you’re running power to it, the contacts
will shower sparks of electricity when you
disconnect them. And since we’re working
with explosive gases, I’m sure you can figure
out why that’s a really big problem.
So to reduce the risk of blowing ourselves
up, let’s connect the power on the battery
side instead.
This way, if the terminals spark when we make
the connection, we’ll be so far away from
the gas that it won’t be much of a hazard.
Now look how fast the gas starts filling up
this balloon. At 24 volts, the generator is
producing around 5 liters of hydroxy gas per
minute, so it takes less than 2 minutes to
fill the balloon completely.
And check this out. If we pull the balloon
off the hose and let it go, it floats.
The elastic keeps all the gas trapped inside,
and since the hydrogen is lighter than air,
it rises to the ceiling just like a helium
balloon would do. And to make sure it doesn’t
float away and blow something up, it’s a
good idea to tie it down somewhere safe.
Now what do you think would happen if we replaced
the ribbon, with a fuse? I know what you’re
thinking, but rather than lighting them and
sending them into the sky, let’s tape them
to a rod instead so you can see exactly what
happens the moment the sparks get through
the rubber. It ignites the gas and makes a
very satisfying bang, that kind of sounds
like gunshot.
When the balloons explode, the gas simply
turns back into steam and water vapor. And
absorbs back in with the atmosphere.
Now I tried filling another balloon, even
bigger, and look how buoyant and lively it
is now. To push the boundaries even further,
I went ahead made a whole bunch more, and
it’s pretty mind blowing to realize, that
we just filled these party balloons, with
gas we made, from water.
To top it all off, I picked up a SpongeBob
balloon from a local party store, and filled
him up, until he was about ready to burst.
Don’t let that big grin on his face fool
you, because our friend SpongeBob has just
become, a SpongeBomb.
I tied him down to make sure he wouldn’t
float away, then lit a fuse behind his back
and got really really, really, far away.
When our little friend finally went off, the
shockwave was so powerful, that it actually
shook the windows on the house.
Well now you know what happens when electrolyzed
water is trapped inside a balloon, and set
off with a fuse. And while I’m not suggesting
this is something you should try, if you’re
going to do it anyway, make sure you use extreme
caution, and just be prepared for the police to show up.
Well that’s it for now. If you like this
video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com